[Music]
Disney themselves reimagined our
favorite princesses as emojis and we
couldn't be happier you can now play
emoji blitz on your cell phone to
collect hundreds of emojis and we are
already a fan of the game are you
curious to know what they look like stay
tuned to see if your favorite Disney
character made the list if this is your
first time visiting our channel don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up today we are
showing you ten Disney Princesses
reimagined as emojis Cinderella
the princess is more in love than ever
in this new emoji she is probably
dancing with the prince right now but
all of this wouldn't be possible without
the help of her fairy godmother with
magic she was able to turn the servant
into the most beautiful woman at the
ball and this is how she got the chance
to meet men who quickly fell in love
with her but do you know that the
transformation of Cinderella's torn
dress to the white ball gown was
Disney's favorite piece of animation and
to make sure she looked her best more
than 90% of the movie was done in live
action before animation dancers acted
the scene so the animators could know
how to draw them even the carriage was
actually a live action model painted
with white black lines and the cat
lucifer was modeled after the cat of one
of the animators it was the first time
this technique was used and the movie
was a success and can you guess which
Disney princess is next on our list
we'll give you a clue with three emojis
a fish music notes and footsteps can you
guess who this Disney Princess is the
Little Mermaid
it is Ariel The Little Mermaid the young
princess loves singing under the sea and
discovering all the amazing things you
can usually find on the land and as soon
as she fell in love with Prince Eric she
had a great reason to be a part of his
world but Ursula took advantage of the
situation when she made a deal with the
mermaid the witch gave her legs in
exchange for her voice and then tried to
steal her men
but what saved Ariel is that she was the
nicest girl but also the most beautiful
one Eric ever saw the mermaid loved
discovering things and there are plenty
of amazing things we can find in this
movie too in the opening scene you can
briefly see Mickey Mouse Donald Duck and
Goofy in the crowd of sea people it is
also possible to see a pane
on the wall and Eric's castle the two
people posing in the picture appear to
be Aurora and Prince Philip from
Sleeping Beauty could the two families
be related and this is not the only
princess ariel could be associated with
because of her magical powers once again
we'll give you three emojis to let you
guess in which movie you can see her a
snowflake a queen and a snowman this
should be an easy one do you know what
this film is frozen Elsa is the queen
who is associated with water even if ice
is much colder than what you can usually
find under the sea the Queen and your
sister Princess Anna know that their
relationship is more important than the
love of a man and if you are looking for
someone to warm your heart your friends
Olaf and spend are those you should be
looking for but no matter what we always
need a big sister to keep us from
marrying a man just met like the other
princesses did and these two girls are
already really impressive by themselves
it took at least fifty animators to
create the castle Elsa built in less
than a minute but that was not the
funniest thing to animate a live
reindeer was brought to the animating
studio so that the animators could study
its movements and draw Sven director
Jennifer Lee said that it was the best
moment during production frozen really
deserves to be the highest-grossing
animated and musical film of all time
and the Queen is not the only one who
doesn't need a man to live happily ever
after another character on our list is
also happier on her own the emojis we'll
use to represent her are a sword a woman
cutting her hair and a dragon do you
know who it is
Mulan this Disney character doesn't need
a man she can actually become one her
family expected her to learn how to be a
good housewife and fall in love with the
man but this is not what she wanted she
wanted to be a warrior and fight for her
country her ancestors ordered the great
stone dragon to help her on her journey
and this funny friend was there to help
her hide her identity at that time
Disney developed an interest in Asian
themed legends and combined many of
their ideas to create the story of Mulan
to make sure the movie looked perfect
members of the creative team traveled to
China for three weeks they took
photographs and did many drawings for
inspiration to soak up local culture and
to learn more about the original legend
they also wanted the art style to be
closer to the Chinese paintings with
watercolor and
or design you can see all those little
details in the background but Milan is
not the only movie you should watch if
you want to learn about a different
culture and once again we'll give you
three emojis as hints a flower a chicken
and someone on a boat do you know who
she could be Moana
here comes our favorite Polynesian
princess Moana the new Disney characters
sailed out on a mission to save her
people she met the demigod Maui who
guided her on her ancient quest as they
encountered enormous monsters this is
how Moana discovered a treasure that was
more important than what she would ever
imagined her own identity if you haven't
seen this movie yet there are many
things you should know about Moana the
directors were intrigued by the rich
culture of this country and they went on
research trips to Fiji Samoa and Tahiti
they wanted to meet the people who live
there and learn more about their culture
the directors also worked with experts
to make sure that the film was
culturally accurate and sensitive this
is why Maui is not bald anymore and why
you won't see mallanna throwing a
tantrum by throwing coconuts after nine
versions they were finally able to bring
to life the movie as we know it and
there is another princess that we loved
even though she lives far away from
Polynesia this time the hints are going
to be a little more difficult three
emojis are an apple a prince and a
monkey do you know who it is we will
give you one more second to think about
it Aladdin the right answer was Jasmine
who lived in an Arabian country the
princess was tricked into marrying a man
that she hates but fortunately a street
urchin was there to save her with the
help of a genie who made three of his
wishes come true they both fell in love
with each other as they were flying on a
magic carpet Aladdin was quickly seduced
by the princess's beauty and so were we
did you know that jasmine looks so good
that the animators had to make Prince
Ellie more handsome Aladdin was first
based on Michael J Fox but he did not
have enough appeal to women this is why
one of the creators asked to make him
look more like Tom Cruise they also made
him older took off his shirt and made
him more confident this is how he became
the man Jasmine could risk her life for
would you do the same thing for him he
is certainly way better than Jafar there
is another Disney princess who didn't
want to marry someone that she didn't
love we'll show you three emojis to let
you know who it is
a horse a bear and a bow and arrow we
know you'll get this one can you guess
what movie it is brave the princess we
were talking about is Merida the redhead
who didn't want to have anything to do
with royalty and Men this is why she
decided to compete for her own hand so
she wouldn't have to marry anyone
unfortunately Disney didn't turn all our
favorite Disney Princesses into emojis
yet so just like the independent
character we had to do it by ourselves
and artists already imagined Merida as
an emoji but Disney also gave us the
chance to create our own characters here
is the princess when she is surprised
sticks her tongue out and laughs out
loud there are so many things you can do
with this app and the work of animators
was really interesting too she was the
first Disney Pixar princess and Pixar's
first female protagonists the two
additional software was developed for
this film one of them was used to allow
simulation Emeritus 1,500 strands of
hair curls to make them move together
with her movements her hair is just as
wild as her and that's why her name
suits her perfectly Merida means to
rebel in Hebrew but do you know what
other Disney character had a temperament
that was not like any other we will give
you three hints a star a crocodile and a
clock do you know what the movie is
Peter Pan the Disney character we were
looking for is Tinker Bell even though
she is not a princess the fairy is so
popular that she had to be a part of her
list Peter Pan's sidekick knew what she
wanted and what to do to get it we loved
her funny reactions to all the things
that upset her and we think that her
friends were sometimes doing their best
to make her act this way Tinker Bell was
jealous of Wendy and she had no reason
to be the little fairy was already so
beautiful
Margaret Carrie was the real-life model
for Tinker Bell because she had the
perfect measurements she spent six
months at the Disney studio acting apart
Carrie is also the one who provided the
voice for the red-haired mermaid in
Peter Pan and there is a funny fan
theory about this character many people
believe that she was Ariel's mother
because they look so similar the dates
also add up so the mermaid would have
been 36 years old when she gave birth to
Ariel in 1973 do you think that this
theory makes sense any
now is time to guess who was the next
blonde in our video we'll give you three
hints a horse a lizard and a flower do
you know who this princess is tangled
the blonde girl we were looking for is
Rapunzel and she is probably the most
blonde woman we have ever seen with her
70 foot long hair
the young girl always wished she could
escape her tower but it was not until a
thief accidentally visited her that
Rapunzel saw her dream come true the
whole world had the chance to see how
nice and beautiful this naive girl was
and we loved seeing her so happy in the
outside world but what we love the most
is the way Flynn Rider looks do you know
how he was designed to be so handsome
the creators set up a meeting with
female employees to ask them what makes
a man so good-looking this is how they
designed some features like the eye
color the hair color the style and the
body type and when we look at the thief
we know that they made a great choice
but what we like the most about him is
that he really loves Rapunzel
when Mother Gothel says that she loves
her she always talks about her hair and
not the princess but when Flynn is
affectionate to her he brushes her hair
away to take a better look at her
leaving the tower with him was the best
decision she ever made and there is
another character in this universe who
wanted to escape here are your three
hints a book a clock into cub you know
who this princess is don't you Beauty
and the Beast Belle was the one that
prints and we were looking for when we
saw that her father was trapped by the
Beast the bookworm decided to take his
place behind bars she never knew that
the best way to escape was to make this
man fall in love with her but even when
she had the chance to leave the castle
she decided to stay because she liked
him so much no one can resist her look
neither we nor Gaston but there is
something you probably didn't notice in
the film you know that Belle is the only
person in this town who wears blue until
she meets the Beast
another misfit who wears blue and has
blue eyes in this movie the red
represents a bad character like Gaston
the Beast is wearing a red cape too at
the beginning of the movie but the more
he gets to know Belle the more his
clothes turn into purple and then into
blue it is really impressive to know
that creators thought about all of these
things this was the last princess on our
list but if
or you can create your own emoji online
you can even turn yourself into a Disney
character if you want to if these movies
taught us one thing it is that there is
no limit to what imagination can do and
that's it for 10 Disney Princesses
reimagined as emojis what was your
favorite emoji and what would you use it
for don't forget to tell us in the
comments down below and like this video
if you guessed who the Disney Princesses
were for more stories like this don't
forget to subscribe and watch 10 Disney
characters reimagined as teenagers
thanks for watching
[Music]